[Musik]
mikrochirurgie die lebensgeschichte von
rosmarie freak ist so wundersam dass er
sich allemal lohnt sie zu erzählen
nur das einstige bauernmädchen aus
oberbüren im kanton st gallen findet sie
sei nicht der rede wert und einen film
über sie müsse man schon gar nicht
machen
sonst in ordnung
die menschen sind allein
ihren traumberuf krankenschwester konnte
rosmarie freak nicht erlernen zu
schlecht in der schule hat es geheißen
heute ist sie 68 jährige eine legende
der mikrochirurgie
es ist platz machen
[Musik]
universitätsspital zürich früh morgens
während über 40 jahren war dies der
arbeitsweg von rosmarie flick nicht
einen tag hat sie gefehlt
sie wäre eigentlich längst pensioniert
acht ärzte aus dem in und ausland haben
bei ihr einen kurs gebucht thema
mikrochirurgie hier gerade doch rosmarie
frick zeigt an einer betreuten rate wie
man unter dem mikroskop winzigste gefäße
freilegt und zusammen nicht geübt wird
an einer ratte weil ihr gefäß
durchmesser ungefähr dem des menschen
entspricht
ein millimeter alles ist so klein dass
man nadel und faden von bloßem auge
nicht sieht
während vier kurstagen kriegen die ärzte
eine einführung in dieses äußerst feine
handwerk bisher es beim patienten
anwenden können wird es jahre dauern
vor 50 jahren wurde diese bahnbrechende
technik an der neurochirurgischen klinik
am unispital zürich entwickelt wo
kreienbühl war der gründe der ersten
neurochirurgischen abteilung der schweiz
und riemers klinikleiter verstärkte der
1950 er jahre ein junger türke fatih
akin ja statt gesetz das
operationsmikroskop in der
neurochirurgie ein und macht er 1967 als
weltweit erster eine bypassoperation an
den hirn gefäßen zusammen mit dem
provider gaza gilt wir uns in der
operationsabteilung mal umlage wenn ich
biete der verfasser das schweizer
fernsehen sendete damals live aus dem
unispital dank der neuartigen technik
konnten zum beispiel schlaganfälle
behandelt werden
zürich wurde zum mekka der
neurochirurgie
[Musik]
exakt diese technik klärt rosmarie frick
noch heute beinahe jeder chirurg
weltweit hat die basis der modernen
mikrochirurgie bei ihr gelernt die
disziplin die sie von sich verlangt
fordert sie auch von den kursteilnehmern
ein
warum auch es ist ja bitte
das ist ein paar cent für mich nicht nur
eine ratte eigenwillig ist jedoch so
unkonventionell wie alles an packt so
speziell ist auch ihr werdegang
weil man sie als krankenschwester nicht
wollte landete sie als schwestern hilfe
auf der neurologie am uni spital in
zürich interesse hatte die junge frau
aber vor allem an der arbeit im labor an
der forschung
es war die zeit als in zürich professor
garcia spielt die mikrobiologie
revolutionierte und operationen an den
hirn gefäßen durchführte rosmarie shrek
hat diese neuartige technik gepackt
das hält nach der arbeit ist es zu hören
war
fasziniert die familie und bitten
experiment nicht helfen
mit unermüdlichem fleiß übte sie sich in
der filigranen arbeit sie strebte die
perfekte gefäß zusammenführung an das
sind das wirklich funktioniert hätte
hätte doch hier übernachtet und prof
[Musik]
an einem kurs tag kennt rosmarie freak
würde hause nachmittag das ist also ganz
schlecht dass sie in dem noch gesagt
haben kann zumal die finger
es ist sehr gut und sie ist sehr streng
und denke das ist wichtig dass man das
lernt sie sich ganz ganz viel arbeit
wie er das zdf hat größere umschlag
unter dem mikroskop und es schaut eher
besonnene taucht tag das macht also die
eigentlich so viel es ist okay höchste
konzentration scheint sie zu beflügeln
im kurs bin ich nicht mehr kann ich im
moment nicht beantworten
jetzt frage ich wie die nachfrage ist
falsch passiert das ist sowieso eher die
heimat weil sie das ist er auftritte sie
die befriedigung wenn sie so macht wenn
ich es gerne hätte
[Musik]
etwa viereinhalb tausend erz der
weltweit herz muss man die krieg auf dem
gebiet der sogenannten an astro moser in
all den jahren ausgebildet beigebracht
hat sie sich alles selbst
learning by doing im jahr war ja nun ist
nicht ok treffliches mythos der
chirurgie ich denke was es ist ich habe
es auch über leid wie sowieso ich meine
event ja zu ihrem kurs gehabt und ich
denke es hat niemand durfte wald muss
mehr gemacht hat als sie und der kamera
aussage besser
trotz ihrer perfekten künste hand
anlegen dem operationssaal durfte sie
nie
bitte name stromkreis also nur im auto
sitze und zwerge und wenn der vater
nicht schön gesetzt ich denke aber das
ist so
schon gesetzt werde ich das nicht
akzeptiert auch klinikleiter regel holt
er sich das rüstzeug für die vaskuläre
mit chirurgie bei ihr also wenn die
zehen aus schüler müsse beurteilen
er war viele würden
ich habe mir ja genauso also der nicht
ganz in gronau ist sehr gut
[Musik]
rosmarie daheim in ihrer
dreizimmerwohnung im sanktgallischen
oberbüren ein seltener moment ihr jahr
ist verplant mit kursen auf der ganzen
welt
das war schon immer so da blieb weder
zeit noch lust für eine beziehung
es ist so dass wir funktionieren sind
sie so viel höher als sie in einer
live-schalte darum ihr nein
30 gäste ihre bezugspersonen sein ihr
bruder und ihre nichten und neffen die
alle um die ecke wohnen und ganz wichtig
die große neffen die puppen alessandra
und giuliano hütet sie regelmäßig und
kocht auch für sie ja sie hätte gerne
kinder gehabt sagt sie aber das habe
sich eben nicht ergeben
[Musik]
basiert die arbeit bedeutet obwohl sie
darüber kaum worte verlieren mag davon
zeugen geschenke aus aller welt in ihrer
wohnung fein säuberlich aufgereihten
andenken an ihre unzähligen kurzeinsätze
[Musik]
nicht einmal die mutter mit der sie
wären 20 jahren in dieser wohnung
zusammengelebt hat konnte sie von der
arbeit abhalten geschaffen was ich jetzt
leider gottes ist das wirklich so
das sofa liegen und wie lange sie denken
wenn ihr so viel spaß der stadt freuen
[Musik]
wieder steht eine reise an
es geht in die türkei
sie ist gebucht für deine kurs woche in
istanbul
egal wo rosmarie landet für
sehenswürdigkeiten hat sie wenig übrig
[Musik]
wo auch immer sie ist das drum und dran
der reise ist jeweils vom spital
organisiert
[Musik]
ansprüche hat sie keine
hauptsache im hotelzimmer steht ein
fernseher
sie wird sich die halbe nacht um die
ohren schlagen sie brauche höchstens
drei bis vier stunden schlaf immer sport
egal war
denn sie verblüfft mich immer wieder die
rosmarie flick
[Musik]
ausnahmsweise hat sie in istanbul einen
tag mehr eingeplant als bloß die
kurstage sie ist eingeladen bei ihrem
mentor und beruflich wichtigsten
weggefährten
denn mittlerweile 93 jährigen garcia
shakil mit seiner frau drei jahren lebt
er einer der bedeutendsten
neurochirurgen des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
seit ein paar jahren wieder in der
türkei sie treffen sich regelmäßig denn
auch der yen hat damals in zürich
gearbeitet
rosmarie nennt es eine freundschaft
pässe man spürt dass sich da drei seit
einer gefühlten ewigkeit kennen und
einander blind vertrauen
20 jahre haben sie zusammengearbeitet
der damalige leiter der klinik in zürich
casillas erinnert sich wie rosmarie ohne
entsprechende ausbildung ins team kam es
war der notwendigkeit und sie sofort
bereit gewesen anzuweisen wahrscheinlich
schon es gibt immer noch leute wie die
frage ist immer ob man doch so einfach
fragt professor
sie haben mir die möglichkeit gegeben
dass ich im labor arbeiten darf und dass
ich immer zu arbeiten durfte sich
schließlich hinter mir gestanden wäre
wäre es nicht gegangen
das stimmt auch nicht glaube heutzutage
das kann man nicht sagen oder ja ich
glaube nicht weiter bieten jetzt zu
viele regeln und sie hat dann im laufe
der zeit zu einer meisterschaft
entwickelt dies einzig in der welt
das ganze ist in ihrem gehirn endliche
sie hat im gehirn bestimmten gebieten
zielgruppen so hochgezüchtet und sie
ganz die operation des fast ohne
mikroskop
[Musik]
es sind auch drei die nie aufgehört
haben zu arbeiten
am nächsten morgen treffe ich im
universitätsspital ihr die treppe in
istanbul alle wieder gas ist eklig da
bespricht operationen und schreibt mit
der yen an seinem neuesten buch zum
thema hier in wendungen eine von
zahlreichen publikationen nebenan
bereitet rosmarie den kurs vor
wie immer checkt sie alles ab
würste der rallye-star der kurs von 1
aber dir das sagt mir mit der für zwölf
statt unser doktor oder war das noch
nicht
ich kenne es wird sich herausstellen
dass er ein kursteilnehmer ist
willkommen wie geht es ihnen
und dann kommt der jetzige leiter der
klinik und türen
vor einem jahr hatte rosmarie freak im
namen der klinik den ehrendoktor die
bereich ich habe hier nichts gegeben sie
hat schon alles
für mich ist sie die beste professorin
der beste dort es war uns eine große
ehre hier diese auszeichnung zu geben
[Musik]
sie ist die wichtigste ausbilderin in
der medizin eine der wichtigsten
danke und sie ist auch meine sie können
das hier auf machen auch dieses detail
entgeht dir kurz vor kursbeginn nicht
die krawatte muss weg und rosmarie frick
ist einmal mehr in ihrem element
entschuldigung die smartphones müssen
ausgeschaltet werden im labor sind
smartphones nicht erlaubt denn sie weg
stopp
schauen sie da rein
nein ich lebe da sonst die hoffen es
rund 1000
aber das hätte vielleicht system wartet
seit ihrer krankenschwester werden und
das ist
[Musik]